This is a site we have built with grids
integrated into the login and
operational flows.
I'm going to log in now.
I copy the grids URL from the site
and paste it here.
Hitting okay.
I am then asked to confirm the messenger
signature request or the message
signature request.
I hit okay
and you'll see I am now logged in.
Almost instantaneously, I am logged in
to the secure client portal and
dashboard.
No password. No credential transmitted.
Now I'm going to show you a transaction.
I generate a payout to be signed.
This could be any transaction type.
I again copy the grids URL. I paste it
into the grids URL box
and I now get a transaction signature
request.
The account, the chain, the network ID,
the originating URL, and the transaction
data. I hit okay.
That's already done.
The transaction settled in under 3
seconds. You can see the transaction
hash. This is the proof of work open
resource blockchain Groot that is the
base of the Gajumaru making the internet
of economics possible. 1,846,200
more transactionally efficient than
Bitcoin with 8.23 times greater network
security in commercial use.
Both the login and the transaction were
conducted using grids. There was no
direct credential interaction on the
connected layer.
Only the origination of the instruction
to the dead drop protocol, as you saw.
One more.
This is Gajumaru Market, the world's
first on-chain marketplace for goods and
services.
Currently in testnet.
You will note that here we see a QR
code.
This is how Gajumaru will operate. You
scan the QR code
and by the same mechanic, login.
For now, I'm going to use the grids URL.
Again,
login here,
confirm here,
hit continue here,
and I am logged in.
Same mechanism. No password.
No database to breach.